[Music]
not an unusual sight in the netherlands
these days
tractors on the streets of the hague
joining a protest
as the police try to block them it
becomes clear that stopping a tractor
isn't easy
we hope that the government will
understand that the netherlands can't
exist without farmers
the netherlands needs farmers we are
producing the most sustainable food
worldwide
so without us i don't know who will feed
all these people after milking his cows
dairy farmer jan van der wint left his
farm to get some answers from the
government
for generations his family has farmed in
an area
where experts now say there's no future
for large farms
it's just not sustainable if a
government target of nitrogen emission
reduction
is to be met we also don't want the
environment to be polluted
there is no debate about that but now
the netherlands wants to take drastic
steps and farmers are the first to be
targeted and i am concerned that in ten
years
when farms are gone we will regret this
like more than fifty thousand dutch
farmers his seventeen-year-old son
tom who is keen to continue the farm has
no idea what lies ahead
[Music]
young farmers driving for hours on their
tractors to demand certainty about their
future
if ecologists environmental groups and
increasingly politicians have their way
farming as we know it in the netherlands
can't exist any longer
a message many here are not ready to
hear
and here you see a lot of dead trees and
dying trees with very low
vitality with very low leaves an expert
on the effects of nitrogen emissions
researcher roland bobbing wrote an
alarming report for greenpeace
his conclusion large parts of the dutch
ecosystem have been so badly affected
that they will be lost if the government
does not act now
i think it is very urgent
and i mean you cannot do it in one or
two years you need maybe five to ten
years
a really high reduction of the nitrogen
deposition maybe
50 to 70 percent and therefore you need
a
different agricultural system in the
netherlands
greenpeace has threatened to take the
dutch state to court for violating
european regulations if the government
does not reduce nitrogen emissions much
further
amidst all the pressure some farmers are
starting to realize that business as
usual
won't be an option for much longer
but farmers organizations say billions
of euros are needed to save dutch farms
and make them
environmental friendly staff farsen al
jazeera
the hague